in today's morning rounds controversial
new research surrounding the meat in our
diets new guidelines in the journal
Annals of internal medicine say you do
not need to cut back on red or processed
meat the researchers say there's a weak
connection between meat and disease but
some US health organizations are pushing
back one even filed a petition with the
FTC to quote correct false statements
regarding consumption of red and
processed meat the American Heart
Association the American Cancer Society
and the American College of Cardiology
all reiterated their recommendation to
cut red meat consumption our dr. Tara
and Narula
cardiologist is here to break it all
down Tara good morning good morning I'm
confused what what's going on so let's
talk about what this was okay this was a
private group that basically decided to
go back and look at prior nutrition
research as it relates to meat
consumption this was not new research
they put it all together and in fact
they found that you know what there is a
benefit in terms of decreases in
cardiovascular disease mortality and
cancer if you consume less meat however
they then went the next step to say that
they thought the benefits were small
they thought that this was sort of
uncertain low kind of quality evidence
they looked at people's preferences and
says well people like to eat meat it
fits in with their culture it's hard to
change and then they crafted guidelines
okay these are not guidelines that came
from an official government organization
an official health body it is from this
group of 14 individuals mostly research
scientists who said that you know what
since the benefits of really cutting
meat are there but they're small they're
not really outweighed by the difficulty
it is for a lot of people given their
cultural and quality of life and eating
preferences so go ahead and continue
eating as you my head is spinning like
The Exorcist curious about what do you
and your cardiologist homies say we
should do with this point for me well I
can tell you there was a lot of outrage
in the cardiology community embedded and
amongst others who really felt that this
message is a public health it's a
disservice that's what they called it in
a statement yes major disservice to
public health that's right so they felt
that you know what there is an abundant
body of evidence when you look back that
shows the benefits of reducing red meat
consumption that we know that you know
processed meat
and red-meat are considered carcinogens
that they do have effects on the
cardiovascular system and diabetes they
felt that the analysis was conducted
really improperly that they left out a
lot of data that they didn't use the
best quality methods to analyze it and
that putting people's preferences into a
guideline doesn't really make sense it
would be like saying well I know you
like to smoke and it's tough smoking so
you know what go ahead and keep smoking
this isn't the first time we've had a
study seemed to contradict other studies
so give us a little mini trip to medical
school here how do we tell which studies
we should listen to and which studies to
ignore well you need to understand that
nutrition science is it's hard to do
it's not like the best type of study
which is called a randomized control
trial where we take somebody and put
them on a drug in somebody else and we
don't put them on the drug and then we
follow them over time you can't really
do that easily with diets you can't say
you Tony eat red meat for ten years
Anthony don't eat red meat and then
let's follow you after so what we do is
something called an observational study
where we basically give people
questionnaires to fill out over time
then we follow them and then we see what
happens and then you make inferences you
say well you reported that you didn't
really eat that much meat and then you
didn't develop cancer so there's a lot
of confounded factors okay quickly what
do we do that's right
bottom line I you know all the societies
all of the you know health officials and
are basically saying do not change what
you're doing right now you should
continue to limit read and process okay
you don't have to give it up but limit
it yeah thank you doctor thank you
sorting it out